[Music]
you got started early you were acting as
a kid and I found out today that you
were in the Macy's Day Parade yes I was
I was in a a Children's Theater Company
when I was about 10 11 years old called
the merry mini players very mini players
yeah and we did musicals and stuff and
it was a very actually a very regimented
very tough Theatre Company and we got
booked somehow to do a to do this
musical number at the Thanksgiving Day
Parade we were doing a show called the
incredible feelings show where we each
played a feeling yeah and each kid
played a different feeling yes and we
wear different colored unitards and I
this is for real and I had a wear this
like purple unitard and we I just all I
remember is we had to get up like at 3
o'clock in the morning it was freezing
and we went out there and it was very it
was nerve-wracking because right
television and we did this incredible
feeling number and I think we all sort
of walked away with an incredible
feeling of shame purpley shame yeah well
I mean without a doubt it's all gone so
well for you today was this you know
that you had a hand and footprint
ceremony it yes it Grauman's Chinese
yeah theatre yes this is this is
something it's been around
I was gonna say I just did it on my own
nobody was there
just hold out the sidewalk and put fresh
cement there like coffee here Hollywood
Boulevard you can get away with anything
no yeah it was yeah it was really cool
and weird and surreal and it was crazy I
mean it was it's it felt like a weird
dream because and you were introduced by
by Tom Cruise that's unbelievable
introduces you which was all making a
part of this felt like this weird
fantasy dream where Tom Cruise is saying
congratulations Ben to me yeah and you
know and then um Michael Jordan comes
out and does a slam dunk over a
Lamborghini it was a crazy party you put
your hands and your feet we actually
have a photograph of this yes that's
gonna be there for all time you're at
the legends now some incredible
handwriting there isn't that yeah I'm
amazing you could get your hands and
feet that submit at the same time yeah
we thought you were double to okay yeah
yeah there's a whole process and it's
all down to the minute at 10:02 put
hands in cement 10:03 take hands out of
cement and then the guy comes and cleans
it up for you and gets it make it makes
it look good are you are you happy with
like I've never liked it my hand my
right hands are weirdly abnormally like
paddles they're kind of large and weird
you're you have large hands yeah I have
a friend who calls my hand the claw he's
a good friend and so yeah so it was
weird I feel like I have like hands for
somebody yourself what are your hands
like I don't know I think I have fairly
yeah let's see look at that right you've
got a big hand for that way I'm probably
like a foot shorter than you yeah okay
all right anyone tuning in right now
thinks we're doing a mind map
this is actually a scene from the
incredible feeling sure now I'm feeling
shame